[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers will answer your questions give
me the V suffice to bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon hi John how are you I'm doing
well I you know in my new book turtles
all the way down comes out in about two
weeks and I'm sort of freaking out but
it occurs to me that you will know the
pleasure of this particular freakout
sometime next year when your novel comes
out yeah there's a number of times in
the past a little while where you've
been like talking about something that I
know I can't talk about which I hate
doing and I never want to do and and so
I didn't for the most part and then now
it's happening the thing that I've been
working on and not able to talk about is
the real thing now and I I have a book
that I wrote and now have to revise John
this this process is time-consuming ya
know I mean that's why it takes me uh
years between books but I have absolute
faith in you you're gonna be okay
but it is it's time-consuming and it's
intimidating but you're a really good
writer and you're gonna be it's gonna be
great I'm not worried I'm not worried I
am a little worried that you're not
going to put all of your energy into the
tour because you're gonna have to revise
during tour and I want to spend the
entire tour playing on the Super
Nintendo classic mini thing that I just
bought well I'm definitely gonna be
revising on tour because the the
deadlines I have been given is quite
aggressive
well but that's fine but you and I have
to play a lot of Super Mario Kart well
you can take that up with my editor who
I have now I have an editor it's weird
I'm so excited for you so for those of
you know no eggs not that good at self
promo his new book is it's gonna be
called this first book it's gonna be
called an absolutely remarkable thing
it's coming out in the fall of 2018 and
I am thrilled it is an absolutely
remarkable thing you haven't read it yet
so you don't know it could be terrible
the one thing I will say about an
absolutely remarkable thing is that it
does not pass the mom test in that she
cannot remember the title on the other
hand the thing that is the best about it
is way back in 2007 my friend Maureen
Johnson observed that many book titles
would get better when you add in your
pants to the end of them absolutely
remarkable thing in your pants is one of
the greatest in your pants book titles
of all time it was considered it was
really the only the only thing I needed
for it for it to be good that's all I
was hoping for you know I kind of wanted
it to spell out fart but I gave up on
that goal and so just got a art instead
oh man well I am I'm really thrilled for
you and really proud of you and I guess
it remains to be seen which green
brother will rule the roost of
publishing but I am really excited for
you I really now regret not finding a
way to make the acronym fart under the
radar and penguin wouldn't have noticed
they just literally like you know
everybody just be like seed on the
shelves and then when it comes to
talking about the book because it's a
rather long title you just have to say
well when I was imagining the main
character in fart it would be so good
opens something that happens in your
pants go ahead and give me a short poem
John alright this poem we sent in by
Michelle it's called splinter by Carl
Sandburg
is very short and it's about fall so
it's seasonally appropriate the voice of
the last cricket across the first frost
is one kind of goodbye it is so thin a
splinter of singing just a little early
fall poem for you Hank can I share with
you a question from our listeners yeah
please do
alright this question comes from Colleen
who writes to your brother's green I
love listening to the pod and I'm
excited to see you in st. Paul next
month I'm also excited to be visiting
Minnesota Colleen I am a kindergarten
teacher who is slowly burning out my
kids and coworkers are amazing but the
demands placed on all of us are becoming
increasingly impossible and to add to it
I have a particularly large and
difficult class this year I'm John's age
and wondering if it's too late to change
careers my husband and I have two
kids we cannot support ourselves on his
salary alone so taking a few years for
the family or more schooling is not an
option what could my next career be
keeping it Coleen what a great
anticipate sign-off that's good that's
good yeah there there maybe are the sort
of the same careers in other places that
you could be looking at like oftentimes
I will hire video editors who are
currently video editors at other video
editing companies and but they will like
the job better we're working for me
because it will be more pay or it will
be less pressure or a cooler thing so
maybe there are kindergartens out there
that aren't so hard maybe but I would
say that there's also an opportunity to
do lots of other jobs I mean I always
recommend talking to your friends and
networking is a horrible word but it is
by far I think the most effective way to
find jobs so go talk to your friends
talk to other parents at soccer games
say I am a kindergarten teacher but I'm
looking for interesting new
opportunities if you hear of anything
please let me know I think that tends to
be the way that most people actually get
jobs LinkedIn and everything is great
but I think there's no replacement for
networking the other thing that I'd say
Colleen is that it in my opinion your
skillset is incredibly useful in a lot
of different careers like a lot of
project management careers because if
you can like handle a classroom full of
five and six year old children as far as
I'm concerned you can do almost anything
in terms of like organization and
administration yeah I mean managing for
the most part is just just controlling
controlling people who are who are
letting their base instincts Drive them
which is definitely kindergarten
teaching yeah that's it that's that is a
great point John yeah I remember the
other thing is that you'll probably be
calm under pressure which is useful like
I remember when I started working at
bookless magazine
I'm not generally this is gonna surprise
you Hank but I'm not generally known for
being a calm person but when when I
first started working a book
magazine my previous job had been at a
Children's Hospital and everyone would
be so upset about the deadlines at book
Liston is the magazine gonna come out on
time and I would just be like you know
what guys the magazines come out on time
like every two weeks for the last 104
years I think it's gonna be fine
nobody's gonna die today that's good
yeah de-escalation because because you
really can't be somebody who escalates
if you're a kindergarten teacher no you
cannot be a catastrophize er if you're a
kindergarten teacher like if a
five-year-old is like I cannot believe
that Jimmy stole my crayons you can't be
like oh my god oh wow that really is a
deal oh man we need to call the
principal the media in fact you know
what we need to call the president yeah
is he can de-escalate a crisis oh man
I'm glad I'm glad that I have gotten a
fair amount of deal de-escalation
training before having a child hopefully
that will be a positive thing for both
of us this next question is from Tyler
who asks dear Hank and John how long
/wel do you have to know someone before
you should or it makes sense to go to
their wedding I have two friends whom I
have acted with in a play that are
getting married I've only known them for
about four months but in that time we
were pretty close as theatre makes you
do the young lady posted on Facebook
saying if you would like a wedding
invite please send me your address
why is she putting the burden of
choosing who goes and who doesn't on us
Tyler yeah no this isn't how attics work
well also like I mean is there a can I
look up her Facebook and ask for an
invite to the wedding like because I
don't mind as long as there's an open
bar I don't mind spending a Saturday
afternoon with strangers but what in the
sweet name of hell is this I mean just
when I thought that I understood the
brave new world of Internet discourse
suddenly what huh I don't know don't
Tyler no Tyler back away just walk
slowly away from this situation delete
your Facebook and just try to reset your
life yeah yeah spend a little time in
the woods this oh man I like that's just
way way too much like what does this
person like everyone who follows them on
Facebook enough for them to come to
their wedding because that is no I feel
about everyone who follows me on my
facebook maybe it is a like strategy for
dealing with really difficult or
annoying parents like if the parents are
like we need you to invite like these 72
people you don't know maybe they can be
like you know what fine but the solution
to pollution is dilution and I'm
inviting everyone from my facebook
there's gonna be 4,000 people at this
wedding we're surfing nothing but Pabst
Blue Ribbon beer and you can bring all
of your friends there's no food yeah
maybe the keg is big enough for two
people thank you yeah Tyler don't go to
this wedding that is my that is my .
recommendation this next question comes
from Hayley who writes Dear John and
Hank I'm 20 years old and I only
recently learned how to whistle and can
we pause for a second so I can just tell
you something yeah sure I don't know if
I've told you this before but to get
Willie inside when he's outside Sarah
and I whistle we say to get him inside
that's the whistle to get Willie inside
and
and Alice don't know how to whistle but
they also like to get Willie inside so
what they say when they want to get
Willie inside is this cute it's so cute
Mel to me it's me oh it's like when
Alice says I'm upside down when she's
right-side up and says I'm right-side up
when she's upside down like it's so
freakin cute and all of this is in front
of you I can't wait anyway Haley has
just learned how to whistle
congratulations Haley I'm happy that I
can finally whistle but now I find
myself with a serious problem I can't
stop whistle this is a serious problem
oh it's a it's a crisis for everyone
around you maybe it's because I feel
like I have 20 whistle this year's to
make up for or maybe I'm just practicing
now that I'm addicted to it this
wouldn't be a big deal but I live with a
roommate in a studio apartment oh my oh
wow
and I think I'm driving her crazy with
all the whistling oh you don't need to
think Haley you need to stop the
whistling how can I stop whistling and
move on in my life
best whistles Haley that's a fantastic
sign it all got worth it at the end
there it all I mean a paid off big time
so Hank in addition to being as you know
a really great singer I am also I am
also an off-key Whistler like I also
can't whistle correctly yeah I'm not
great at whistling either I have a
couple of friends who are like super
high quality like you should be a
professional Whistler whistlers yeah
that is not me
you want to play a game real quick where
we whistle tunes back and forth to each
other and I try to guess what you're
whistling okay all right here's me ready
okay
anything uh yeah yeah dock dock of the
bay is a dock of the Benton on the duck
and the bay boat is ready
exactly now you now now you you bring me
why right it's got to be something I
recognize remember I only know about
seven song this time do do do do do do
do do I have no idea what that song is
is it hey now you're an all star by
Smash Mouth yes that is literally one of
the seven songs I know I know I figured
it was gonna be one of them Hank
good job say to Haley what is the
situation I mean to stop whistling maybe
I like with anything that becomes
compulsive it can be very hard to stop
doing things but maybe that maybe
there's some kind of like noise
activated shock collar that you can
acquire no that's a terrible idea
this is some negative reinforcement my
my first ever therapist when I described
like the experience of these like
obsessive thought spirals that I would
fall into I remember my first ever
therapist said and I'm quoting directly
you need to stop thinking like that
and I was like oh yeah no that's thanks
for that helpful advice
obviously Haley wishes that she lived in
a world in which she wasn't whistling so
much here's my advice Haley I wonder if
you can whistle to yourself like whistle
silently the way that you like talk to
yourself I wonder if you could practice
some self whistling I do that with
talking a lot and Katherine will
sometimes do you like what are you doing
and I will just my mouth will be moving
very small Lee and oh yeah I do that a
lot
it's why I do that especially when I'm
writing a vlogbrothers video in my head
yes there'll be like are you are you
talking and I'll bet not exactly just
I'm just being real weird yes
oh man this is I mean it's part of the
process speaking of real weird we've got
a question from Jethro who writes Dear
John and Hank when I opened my mouth
photons get in now the photons have no
mass so they don't cause me to gain
weight or anything like question is
what happens to the photons when I close
my mouth do they all get out in the last
moment before it shuts or do some get
trapped in there bounce around until I
next open my mouth and Jethro I love it
so much Jethro this is super good
that's that well I mean I can tell you
actually what happens to with them
that's what I want to know okay i fee I
feel like I feel like I feel like that
that magic of feeling as if they're just
bouncing around and they're waiting to
fly out when you open your mouth again
that's too beautiful I don't want to
ruin it but Photon
when it hits something will will either
be absorbed or it will reflect and so a
very small amount of them will reflect
but then they will reflect and hit
something else very soon afterward you
know they're moving at the speed of
light so it's going to happen very
quickly and and within you know an
imperceptible amount of time after you
close your mouth they will have all been
absorbed by the tissues in your mouth
and your mouth will be slightly warmer'
so there's that probably but yeah they
won't be there when you open your mouth
again unless you could open your mouth
really fast really fast like wait way
faster then I like when you close a door
all the photons they just like they get
absorbed by the room and stop bouncing
around even if you're a little in like a
room made of mirrors that happens
because the ears aren't perfect
basically we're all made out of light
we're all made out of energy if you if
you want to be beautiful about it ya
know it feels like it feels like a reach
it feels like one of those early John
Green novel
science pages and we're definitely not
all made of light I can tell you this
next question comes from Nicole who
writes Dear John and Hank during this
year's project for awesome I purchased a
nerdfighter pen pal perk to make a long
story short the two pen pals I was
placed with never responded at after the
initial message the fantastic team at
project for awesome were very kind to me
but said that no one else has had this
situation
so they were placing me on a list in
case this happens to anyone else but
it's been several months and I'm
beginning to lose hope I'm hoping if you
read this email someone will reach out
to be my nerdfighter pen pal
best wishes Nichole all right Nichole
here's the deal we're gonna uh we're
we're gonna have applications to be your
pen pal no wait we're not doing that
we're not doing that sounds like all
right all right Nichole here's the deal
you know Colleen from earlier who the
kindergarten teacher who's looking to
find a new career she doesn't know this
but she is your new pen pal
oh and have a good news is that you
Nichole now it is your job to get
Colleen and a new job so right well also
those in the loop oh we're gonna we're
gonna hook you up with hailey as well
and you can talk with her and you will
not be able to hear her whistle which is
excellent news for you because it's it's
a penpal situation hopefully hailey
won't write out her whistling's Colleen
and Hailey if you don't want to be
Nicole's pen pal don't worry her
previous two pen pals also rejected her
so I'm sure her heart won't be broken or
anything ah all right job this next
question comes from Dalia who asks what
is the proper etiquette for handing
change to a cashier do you place it on
the counter which forces them to pick up
the coins which can be difficult and
irritating or do you try to hand it to
them directly which can result in your
hands
awkwardly touching or dropping the coins
by accident am I the only one who thinks
about this an answer would be much
appreciated yours curiously Dalia hey
Dalia I got great update for you just
we're use credit cards now we don't not
always I mean so when I worked at Steak
and Shake it was a cash-only business
astonishingly and this this came up in
my life all the time when I I don't know
if you know this Hank but the takeout
side of Steak and Shake is called take
home a sack because you were choking
home a sack of burgers mm-hm and so when
someone would come up to the take home a
sack line this would happen all the time
in fact it would almost every time and
in my experience I would rather much
rather personally someone just try to
sort of drop hand the change off in some
way or drop the change into my hand
because it is very diff
to pick up change off of a counter and
in the end I think it's actually from
the perspective of someone who's
somewhat germaphobic actually like
grocer to have to like touch every part
of the penny as you try to like and rip
it from the counter and then just like
what's the slight touch of another human
hand so that is my personal vote but I'm
sure that everybody's experience is
different and really I would think that
most of the time we can solve this
problem with credit cards now this is a
problem that my son Oren has he's 10 and
a half months old
particularly with avocado uh-huh sure
man
it like getting him to pick a piece of
avocado up off the counter is it's so
frustrating to watch and he's just like
he's concentrating and he's brought his
fingers on it and he's pulling it and it
sticks and he just like slides up and
it's still there on the fricking cat
thing in front of his highchair and he's
just like why can't I get this avocado
into my hand yeah so stealing the
surface tension it's hard to how old I
was when I first ate in avocado because
I was definitely older than Oren is now
oh man yeah like when did avocados
happen I feel like we didn't like I did
not encounter an avocado until college
and all of these young people these days
don't know what life was like they don't
understand like Steak and Shake didn't
take credit cards and avocados didn't
exist there was a hard life for us we
walked uphill to school both ways it was
very difficult did I ever tell you by
the way that Sarah's grandfather was an
avocado farmer in California no it's
true it's true not the kind of avocados
that we most commonly eat these days
here in the United States but he he was
an avocado farmer and you still
occasionally see his name on avocados
excuse a avocado again for me John well
now I can't because now I've become
suddenly tremendously self-conscious do
I say avocado weird you say avocado like
you are very American well a lot of
British people say avocado
rosianna how do you say avocado avocado
that is my that's my invitation of
reserved a condo I know what is it like
to treat words so generously as English
people treat them it's like every word
they say it's like they're trying to
like give them a hug and make sure that
it's feelings don't get hurt
ah no avocados in America used to be
called avocado pears which is just
because they're pear-shaped but like
yeah but they don't say that because
people are gonna be very confused when
right away in this sketch on their
dislike evite like take a bite out of it
they'd crack open an avocado pear and be
like this doesn't taste like a pear and
if something very bad has happened to
this pear all right thank you God let's
get to another question for our
listeners this one comes from Allison
who writes hi John and Hank I find
myself in year three of graduate school
working the full-time low-paying
internship writing a thesis and working
on a grant I haven't made it in my
career yet and I already feel burned out
the two of you seemed to do it all even
while maintaining relationships and time
with your families how do you keep
yourselves from burning out how do you
keep going when you're just tired
overworked and underpaid Allison I think
that much more important question
Allison should be asking is how do John
and Hank make it appear that they don't
get burned out yeah the fact that you
don't think that we do is a weight as
far as I can tell but yeah there are
definitely times when I feel like like
I'm failing at one or the other of those
things that I'm concentrating too much
on one and it's hurting the other or
that or that I'm just really done I'm
just done with one of the things that
I'm working on and I have to keep doing
it because it's a responsibility that I
have and that I've signed up for and
people are relying on me I cannot tell
you in our real lives how often Hank
says to me or I say to him that we feel
like we're doing all of our jobs badly
yeah it's one of my biggest worries and
frustrations is feeling like I do too
many things and end up doing them all
poorly and but I also have just a
tremendous amount of support that you
probably don't have working in graduate
school and working at your full-time job
and trying to write a thesis and also
trying to get grant money so that you
can continue to do the work that you
want to do like that is a lot to take on
in a life and I think it's I find it
helpful to sometimes just to say like
okay well the reason I feel overworked
and stressed out and like I'm pressed
past the limit is that I am like that's
real it's not that that you know I'm
some tremendous failure because I can't
do stuff it's because it's real and I
also the other thing I'd say is that
honestly because Hank is my brother and
Hank is the most productive relentless
person I have ever met and I'm in
complete awe of his ability to just do
thing after thing after thing and do
them all well like I also know the
feeling of like looking at other people
and just feeling like I don't I can't do
that and sometimes that's also okay I
think it's okay to just be like I can't
do all this other stuff even if people
other people can do it I can't and
accepting your own limitations and and
and being able to kind of work within
your own strengths and weaknesses I
think is kind of the key to long-term
sustainable workloads uh-huh yeah yeah
and and the only reason I feel like I've
been able to do like like an abnormally
large amount of sort of individual
activities is because one I find them
all very enjoyable and I kind of often
don't have to do them when I stop
finding them enjoyable because I can
find people who will help me keep those
things working and alive after I have
gotten burned out on them or I will sort
of catch my burnout early and find ways
to have people who support me and
support those things after I feel like I
can't do them and so that's an amazing
place of privilege to be able to like
when something is getting to be too much
for when I'm just like over it I can
find people who have that passion that
that I don't have
at the moment and then come back to it
when my passion is back yeah no that is
it that is a huge privilege for sure I
got another question is from Kate dear
brothers green I currently have a pimple
located right at the base of my nostril
and even brushing a finger against it
causes instant pain and death why does
this particulars it hurt so much and how
do I get rid of it I would appreciate
any dubious advices I would like to be
able to watch my face again like a
normal person acne and artichokes Kate
John OH
nose nose stuff man I tell you what I
looked this up John nose pain is some of
the some of the worst pain that you can
have on your body weirdly there was a
man in recently who decided he wanted to
know where it hurt the most on his body
to get stung by a bee and so he stung
himself with a bee every day for a month
on different parts of his body in fact
twice a day because he did a test sting
on his forearm so he could be like okay
this is how much the base level of pain
is and then I will sting myself on
another part of my body to know how much
worse than forearm bee sting that is and
do you want to know where on his whole
body because he stung himself everywhere
it hurt the worst was it the nose it was
the nose and yes he did sting himself on
his penis and it hurt less than getting
stung on the nose in fact it was not
even really like it was you know close
to the top but penis sting was like just
as bad as like armpit sting or up like
palm of the hand sting is like a seven
the nose was a nine like and then like
the nostril and like around the lip area
was the worst area to get stung by a bee
and I feel this I feel this so hard
because I get nose it's on the inside of
my nose sometimes and they hurt so bad
it hurts so bad so bad so I completely
agree but I just I if you don't mind I
would like to ask you to just roll back
the tape a little bit what why hey what
didn't win science I you can't give me
like one of you can't give me like one
fifth of this news story and not fill in
the blanks who is this person
why did they choose to do this don't
tell me for science
because for science you need a much
larger sample size well I mean I don't
think I'm gonna get a much larger sample
size is the thing first off in my
experience what you need in this
situation above all because there is no
solution that I know of to the nose it
is empathy you need people in your life
who care about you and understand how
terrible a nose it is and that is why
Kate I am going to be introducing you to
Nicole see that's right Kate you're
gonna be pen pals with Nicole see
whether you like it or not and remember
she has been dumped by two pen pals so
don't dump her okay what Hank what is
what is going on who did this his name's
Michael Smith he is no it isn't it is no
it isn't that a completely fake name as
anybody who intentionally stung
themselves on the penis with a bee would
do he has created a fake name I mean no
I'm at the Cornell graduate students
page right now I've just clicked on a
page a picture of Michael Smith Smith
research I'm interested in how honeybee
workers sense the size of their colony
and how they make the switch from
investing in survival / growth to
reproduction I spend lots of time
counting bees and looking at drone comb
it does not mention the fact that he
stuck himself on the penis with a beer
and apparently stung himself a total of
a hundred and ninety times over 38 days
and calibrated his experiments with a
single sting on the forearm every time I
mean it's one of those Batman things you
know like it's the the hero we need yeah
so the the nose was a nine out of 10 the
lips was an eight-point seven out of ten
interesting that he got that granular
with it that there was a point seven
going on as penis came in at seven point
three testicles a mere seven hahaha
tying tying for fourth with the cheek
the palm and the armpit I mean I I am
grateful to know this information so
that if I ever get stung in the nose by
a bee I will at least be able to comfort
myself by saying well Michael Smith did
say this
the worst he knows he says he says at
the end of this article in National
Geographic I didn't see a lot of merit
and repeating this with more subjects so
it's not gonna go any deeper with the
research at large Reston he addressed my
concern about sample size head-on which
I appreciate thank you Michael with the
head in fact Jake that reminds me that
today's podcast is brought to you by
Michael Smith Michael Smith this
surprisingly generous soul who agreed to
be stung by a bee 190 times the podcast
is also additionally brought to you by
the solution to pollution which is a
dilution dilution just invite everyone
to your wedding so you don't have to
hang out with your parents weird friends
and today's podcast is brought to you by
the photons in your mouth the photons in
your mouth they're gonna stay there and
finally well not technically but
whatever and vitally this podcast is
brought to you by ilucato pears just
take a big ol bite don't even think
about what might be inside of there or
whether that skin is definitely not to
be eaten just yum yum yum alright we
also have an actual sponsor for today
which is audible
did you know Hank that you can go to
audible.com slash dear Hank or
audible.com slash dear John and get a
free audiobook with a 30-day trial and
that among the free audiobooks you can
get in that deal are The Fault in Our
Stars my most recent novel yeah Turtles
all the way down you can pre-order it it
comes out in two weeks or Looking for
Alaska my first novel or any of my books
but you can also get a lot of other
people's books at audible audible is an
amazing resource it allows you to listen
to high-quality audio books of
everything anything that interests you
but hopefully especially my books
someone asked me on tumblr is your book
gonna be on an audiobook and I was like
I mean it's a it's a book yeah doesn't
that just happen is that is it something
I don't even know is it something that
just does it doesn't always just happen
but I'm sure that it will happen for an
absolutely remarkable thing I'm very
confident of that and very like I might
listen to it on audio
perfectly honest with you yeah I do I do
I listen to so many audiobooks now it's
so good I have gotten straight-up
addicted sometimes I have to like like
Tarab like say okay no you're going to
not you're gonna like be in silence with
yourself because I get I get so caught
up in my audiobooks right now I'm
listening to the queen of the tearling
by Erika Johansen nathir narrated by
Katharine caldron it's really good
laudable also has its own podcasts which
are very cool yeah yeah I listened to
one recently that was um it was like the
this guy got to talk to Bernie Madoff
and like told the whole story of Bernie
Madoff yes and I thought that one was
really fascinating and and that is the
one that I have enjoyed in Phase II more
about how messed up not only that
situation was but the entire financial
industry it's really upsetting yeah I
found that podcast absolutely gripping I
mean it's really interesting to watch
someone sort of try to build
justifications for their behavior while
also knowing it was wrong while also not
being able to process that it was wrong
it's fascinating podcast you can check
it out on audible also get lots of books
and a free month 30-day trial at
audible.com slash dear John that's ear
ible dot-com that they're making they're
making a spell it out now that's serious
that's not okay that's that's a you DIBL
EECOM slash Dear John or dear Hank but
mostly Dear John yeah but if you want to
use to your Hank that would be fine this
next question comes to you I just tell
shutting you up there John I don't even
know what the next question is that
comes last year John audible.com slash
dear Hank this next question oh my
goodness
interesting okay go ahead fine no you go
no you go alright it comes from Joey who
asked dear Hank and John I just wanted
to compliment the phrase of the week
game this week episode 108 it was a
large improvement on that bit and
definitely made it more exciting for us
listeners so and to give you positive
feedback not a kangaroo Joey thank you
for that Joey and for the wonderful name
specific sign off I want to say
that when we create bits here at dear
Hank and John we try to set the bar so
low that we cannot help but jump over it
in the future
mmm yeah working hard at that I also
liked it last week it made me really
excited but I have not heard one yet
from you so I don't know maybe maybe I
have it no maybe it's audible.com slash
to hear John and you're really throwing
me for a loop
rosianna would have been throwing me a
pretty easy softball she debated
audible.com slash Dear John your home
for a free month of audible we've also
got a note here from M in Berkeley I
wanted to read who writes I'm a female
tech executive in my 50s and I love all
the many things you guys do I'll be at
your San Francisco Show no doubt the
oldest attendee no way I bet you will
not be oh now now Wendy but but I really
do appreciate you being there in San
Francisco and spending your Halloween
with us that is going to be our
Halloween spectacular and we're very
excited you have no idea how Halloween
II Hank is going to get anyway I'm very
much looking forward to it when I was in
high school college I relied on my own
1970s nerdfighter esque tribe sci-fi
late Star Trek the original recipe Comic
Cons when they were still in a hotel
ballroom Bob Dylan jam bands and I still
love all these things in the last
episode you recommended wearing personal
fandom garb thus I will be in tie-dye
which brings me back to jam bands funny
to not care about Trey's name it's like
saying the person who wrote Harry Potter
is JK what's her name I share this with
you only to point out that there are
many fandoms throughout space and time
that provide community for us nerds
Diegan and deadheads m in berkeley what
a great email and what a generous
correction thank you
and and I have to say full disclosure I
have been to a Phish concert quite
recently actually and I had a great time
all right Hank let's go back to
questions for a second this one comes
from Jordan who writes Dear John and
Hank I'm 20 year old girl who's a few
months off finishing her university
degree and I've recently been working
for quite a large tech company I've had
the opportunity to purchase stock in
this company and now on the proud
question mark owner of some shares in a
global organization everybody's told me
that stocks are good and I should have
them
I'm also under the impression
but selling them within the first year
of having them incurs a bit of attacks
where I am from Australia the reason I'm
writing now is that I remember listening
to an early dear Hank and John regarding
stocks and all I remember is that I need
to have more than one first off I just
want to pause Jordan and say that coming
to dear Hank and John for market advice
is a great decision but like what do you
do with them do you have to check their
existence daily do they need food and
water they're not Neopets Jordan come on
when do I need to sell them should I
sell them what's the point of having
them if you don't sell them I'm 20 and I
don't know how to share Jordan great
sign-on great high-quality you know
Jordan like honestly and this is this
has been proven by like cats choosing
like picking stocks versus like high
paid analysts picking stocks the best
thing you can do is nothing is just like
have stocks and keep them and it is a
way to save money in a way that and that
money will become more money as you get
older being the age of 20 is a great
time to put some money into investments
because while year-to-year you never
really know how much money you're gonna
make over the you know the last hundred
years of the stock market existing there
has been you know a fairly steady
increase in stock prices as more value
has been added to the economy and more
cool things have been done with money
that the the goal is that if you have
you know a hundred dollars that goes
into your into the stock market when
you're twenty years old by the time you
retire that will be five hundred dollars
and that's not a huge deal when it's a
hundred dollars but if you're putting in
you know a thousand dollars and it's
five thousand if you're putting in ten
thousand and it's fifty thousand that
can really help create stability for you
when you are done with working that's
the so I'm gonna disagree with
everything that Hank just said all right
let's fight about it first off neither
Hank nor I knows that much about
investing money as evidence for this I
would point to the fact that Hank and I
had an extensive conversation last night
where we were both trying to understand
how stock options were true and how
vesting were
and now shares it which I didn't figure
it out either no the other thing that I
was gonna say is that we ended the
conversation by being like this seems
complicated and that was the end so I
can't think of I can't think of a less
financially savvy podcast to visit but I
will say I don't think that doing
nothing in Jordan's particular case is
the right thing to do necessarily so
Jordan you're gonna get these these
shares at some kind of a discount
ostensibly to what they would cost on
the open market and and then they will
like vest over time while you work at
the company hopefully for a while
that's what the company wants certainly
and then you will have the option to
sell them and you're right that short
term capital gains are taxed differently
in Australia than long term capital
gains I think I'm not positive yep but
at some point I actually think that you
should sell the stock in that company
because I don't think that it is always
a good thing to own if you're going to
own stocks which I agree is good I don't
think that you should own stock and only
one company now John it's possible that
the corporate behemoth you work for is
so big that it cannot fail but even very
large banks in America that were deemed
too big to fail and indeed were not
allowed to fail by the government still
saw their share price is reduced by like
8090 percent in the stock market crash
in 2008 so at some point I would
recommend selling that stock and just
buying a what's called an index fund or
some some vehicle through which you can
own a lot of stocks at the same time so
an index fund is basically just you
would own all the companies in Australia
or all the companies that do business in
Australia instead of just one and your
hundred dollars would be kind of split
among all of those companies instead of
just at the one I'm going to assume it's
Google yes John is right you do not want
to put all of your eggs in one basket
obviously the but it's great that you
have
an opera but an opportunity to have the
stock now and just maybe have a piece of
the organization that you're working for
but you know once there is a good time
for you to sell that or invest in other
stocks so that you can have a more
diverse portfolio or just buy an index
fund which has been proven for the most
part to be much better than trying to
pick individual stocks and the index
fund is just like if you're near in
America you just buy the whole S&P 500
and when that goes up your socks go up
when that goes down your investment goes
down and over time the SP tends to go up
and there's that little catastrophe and
then it happened and money doesn't
matter anyway right then we're just
gonna be burning our dollars to stay
warm but Jordan the only thing that I
would ask in exchange for this
high-quality financial advice is write
us and you explained to us how like
vesting and all that and stock options
work as we're a little confused alright
Hank before we get to the news from Mars
and AFC Wimbledon I want to share this
email from Colleen who wrote in to say
Dear John and Hank on your most recent
episode John mentioned that Hot Springs
Arkansas was the best town name in the
state personally I'm from Eureka Springs
no hard feelings interstate rivalries
aside John allow me to introduce you to
greasy corner Arkansas Weiner Arkansas
monkey run Arkansas and toad suck
Arkansas so I officially rescinded my
position Hot Springs Arkansas is the
best town name obviously toad suck
Arkansas digs man I mean I need a shirt
a shirt from toad suck Arkansas so bad
get get me into B we had a lot of really
good name specific sign offs that came
in America whose name is America names
enough god bless america
also maybe my favorite that I have seen
and maybe ever is from Ruth who who
signs off you can't handle the Ruth my
favorite is actually from Torrey which
is the best one I've ever seen she signs
off who lives who dies who tells yours
Torrey I didn't get it until you said it
out loud
oh god it's a winner it's a winner oh
man what a time to be alive Hank what's
the news from Mars this week well a
bunch of people eight of them I think
spent eight months hanging out on the
side of a volcano in Hawaii never
venturing outside of their of their
habitat without spacesuits on living
only with each other and doing their
best to get along and to make that
relationship work for science and so
that NASA can better understand how
people will get along on long missions
with a small number of people ideally
going to Mars and this is a big deal
because there have been times when
astronauts in space have been like this
is terrible and we're gonna basically
mutiny it only happened one time and and
they said to NASA we're gonna stop
working until you change our work hours
and it was like a space strike which is
you know either a labor movement or it's
you know illegally taking over a space
station which you know depending on your
perspective so getting people young
people to spend a bunch of time together
without any contact with anyone else if
they wanted to communicate with the
outside world they had to have about a
20-minute lag which would be you know
like the sort of average amount of time
that the the light takes for it to get
from Mars to earth so you so they
couldn't browse the Internet like normal
people they had to hang out with just
the same people over and over again and
spend eight months doing that on the
side of a volcano in Hawaii which is not
the worst place to hang out I don't
think but maybe nicer than Mars and
ohana ways but how did it go hey well it
went fine they all did well I'm sure
that there will be research papers
published about it but you know in
general these things when they're done
explicitly for the science they you
don't really know that much about it
until all the papers have time to get
written and peer-reviewed and stuff but
they're home now and get to be on the
internet like normal people and I'm sure
are regretting it well I'm sure they're
the first thing that they did
upon leaving their fake Mars was tuned
in to dear Hank and John so hello former
Martians thank you for your service
yes well Hank the newsroom AFC Wimbledon
is wait for it good whoo AFC Wimbledon
went to Blackburn Rovers an away game
against one of the better teams in Ligue
1 in fact Blackburn Rovers once won the
Premier League and everyone felt very
strongly that AFC Wimbledon would lose
that game because that has sort of been
a bit of the trendline with the first
six games of the season but no Blackburn
Rovers lost the game AFC Wimbledon won
the game jacket imagine that AFC
Wimbledon won 1 nil bringing their total
goal scoring for the season up to if I'm
not mistaken for yeah so a1 no victory
and then in the past as you are
listening to this but in the future as I
am reporting at AFC Wimbledon on
September 22nd play the franchise
currently applying its trade in Milton
Keynes is obviously a huge game the no
getting around it
it's the rivalry that shouldn't be but
it is and we'll see I mean I will be
watching the game live on the I follow
AFC Wimbledon app now it's it is cool
now that NIT there's some problems with
the app it's not perfect but it is
really cool that you can watch live
streaming video of Wimbledon playing and
and this game I'm glad that I will not
be there in real life because I'm sure
it will be tense and upsetting but
hopefully it will be tense end up
setting and also thrilling and we will
win that is kind of my big hope I really
really want to win that game I also have
that same hope for you John are things
going better for a particular reason or
is it just the the luck of the dice in
well I mean defensively Wimbledon have
been very solid this season that they've
they've scored fewer goals than almost
any other team actually they've scored
the fewest goals in Ligue 1 but they
also have one of the best
offensive records in Ligue 1 they've
only given up eight goals which I think
would put them like seventh or eighth in
the table if games were only calculated
by how many goals are scored on you so I
think the struggle for Wimbledon is
going to be where the goals are going to
come from without you know without Tom
Eliot and without Otto bio walk and
phenoix and we're starting to see a
little more energy the game before that
AFC Wimbledon drew but they were
creating a lot of offensive chances so
the Dons are currently 16th in the table
which means that they are four spots
north of the relegation zone right where
we like it alright good good job IFC
Wimbledon John is it not the time where
we guess each other's phrases of the
week it is
it is the time where we guess each
other's phrases of the week all right do
you want to try and guess mine I do but
I have no idea what it is I have I I
don't even know if I have a guess let me
I mean let me think if I guess Hank was
your phrase of the week the front door
no no it was not they even say the front
door I mean what was your phrase of the
week was exceptionally easy to hide and
and also we had a great moment for it it
was don't put all your eggs in one
basket oh wow yeah you did questioning
yeah you did that very effectively what
was my phrase of the week I'm gonna
guess the solution to pollution is
dilution I mean it would have been a
great phrase of the week but my friends
now the roost rule the roost which I
snuck in very very early because I said
that I couldn't put it in any later so I
snuck in that thing about how we're
gonna have some kind of like fake
rivalry as writers and to find out who's
gonna rule the roost which of course we
won't really have is what one person's
success does not it really impact
someone else's success except positively
in the case of Brothers
raise the week makes it so you can not
get distracted you gotta be feeling
you've really got a good time so we're
gonna go record this weekend ryan's our
weekly patreon patreon ova podcast about
ryan's increasingly focused on non
Ryan's and but thank you for listening
and thanks to everybody for sending in
their questions we're sorry about all
the questions we don't answer and Hank
thank you for popping with me
I was absolute pleasure this podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins produced by
rosianna halse rojas and Sheridan Gibson
are a head of community and
communication is viktoria bon giorno the
theme music that you're hearing is by
the great gunnarolla if you want to
email us your questions you could do
that at Hank and John at gmail.com we're
also Hank green on Twitter and John
Green on Twitter to find us that though
that bat place and also other places on
the Internet thank you so much for
listening thanks for prodding with me
and as they say in our hometown don't
forget
[Music]